ok Nick you were here at Kirby con curve
econ is all about body positivity how
did you learn how to love yourself I
have to say being a part of the debute
of Yui and being on HGTV really it was
quite a journey to really love myself
but I think when you go through so much
I don't want to say hate but criticism
it makes you do two things you can even
go in a way to please other people or
you could take a good look at yourself
and go this is who I am this is how it's
made and I'm gonna love it and I'm just
gonna shine that confidence through yeah
do you feel like you have to love
yourself before you love someone else
100% I think you make you're better in a
relationship when you fully have that
self-love and love yourself and know who
you are because then you're just so
confident in that relationship yeah
we're so excited for the next chapter of
your life yeah what's it gonna look like
goodness well hopefully a lot of sparkle
and shine um I think you know I'm I'm
really enjoying being an entrepreneur
like I'm very excited for my comeback at
WWE and I'm just beyond excited about
the first-ever all-women's pay-per-view
evolution and just to be a part of that
in that journey but also to be an
entrepreneur like I have a big birthday
coming up in November and it's fun
because it's like this milestone that
I'm hitting and I get to look back and
see what I'm doing and I just have this
goal in my head of what I want to
conquer as an independent woman and I'm
gonna get there and I can't wait to be
on the cover of Forbes so look out yes
not even lady boss you're a boss yeah
like a woman by Abela bus actually
that's we're gonna say Abella boss
speaking of fellas
total Bella's coming back where are we
picking up well that's that's an
interesting question um it's you know
the new me a new journey just with my
family and it's you know it's been as we
all know a hard few months but I have to
say that my Bella army which I think
everyone knows the fans have been so
insanely supportive and the fact that we
got picked up for new season and people
want to continue to watch brie nice
journey it just means so much to us and
we're gonna just continue to be as well
as to be open books and give them
everything we have and they're gonna get
us
everything we're doing from wine country
to birdie be to just me having my new
journey and not that I'm looking for a
new one yet
you know I'm kind of like I'm just right
now in this space of like like we were
talking about really love myself and
that's what I want right now is just to
love me and we're here at New York
Fashion Week so the fashion game is on
point today at Kirby is oh my gosh tell
me what the most affordable thing you're
wearing right now so it would be my boy
shorts underneath my dress but then
besides that it would be I would say my
choker even though I still spent a
little bit I you know it's Fashion Week
like you I I would love to say I wanted
to save but I always when I it's Fashion
Week I have to come in I have to be
ready you know I have to appreciate
Couture that's all I'm doing
[Music]
[Applause]